well the left is going to green extremes
to convince you of their climate
hysteria eco protesters ruining more
priceless works of art with superglue
this weekend and a cnn columnist thinks
americans should throw out their air
conditioners to save the planet i don't
think we'll be trying that with
temperatures reaching 100 degrees but
it's al gore who is sucking up the most
oxygen with this most ridiculous
comparison
the climate deniers
are
really in some ways similar to all of
those almost 400 law enforcement
officers in uvalde texas
who were waiting outside an unlocked
door
while the children were being mastered
they heard the screams they heard the
gunshots and uh nobody stepped forward
greg
your response to the hypocrite of the
climate change maybe all those massages
he got went to his head he's so oh that
was good he's so profoundly disgusting
and not for what he just said but just
for the if the original offense
is mapping climate denier off holocaust
denier so already when they started
doing this business a couple of years
ago they were comparing skeptics not
skeptics to nazis so comparing them to
the police who weren't able to save
those kids that's actually a step up
so it's like every time he says
holocaust denier
i want to punch him in the face because
it is so deeply offensive because we
know what he's doing we know the
undercurrent what he's trying to do is
he's trying to link you to holocaust
denial he's just he's just the scummiest
thing judge you're wearing green
do you have a comment about the green
movement
[Laughter]
you know you know what i as i was
watching him isn't he the guy that
created the internet isn't that the same
allegedly he should say
yeah um you know a guy like that who
wants to talk about you know the world
is coming to an end i say to myself
he has such a pulpit he could really
make a difference if you want to talk
about guns and you want to talk about
crimes and victims he really could say
something i mean i'm sick and tired of
the left talking about the climate
problem and we're all going to be dead
in six or seven years aoc gave us 12
years i think we're now down to seven
years you know tell why don't you tell
each other to stop creating all these
problems they don't want me to eat beef
because they don't like that that they
that the cows have gas they want me to
eat pork i don't like pork i had pigs
i'm not gonna i don't okay pulled pork
maybe but
you know but then you know and don't
tell me i can't have an air conditioner
because people in europe don't have an
air conditioner don't tell me how to
live i don't want to listen to you you
got an issue take care of it yourself i
mean stop imposing it on all of us
that's what the left does they want to
tell us how to live what to eat what to
spend our money on when to mask when to
stay in and they violate every rule in
the book jessica i mean there are ways
to have
a debate or a conversation about
skepticism or the environment but if
you're going to compare people who want
to follow the science on the environment
and climate change and maybe don't have
this big government solution to it to
police officers in uvalde who allowed
children to be murdered
doesn't that turn off a
a big segment of the population or
everybody on an issue that al gore
claims is essential to the future of the
planet well it turned off the majority
of the table i did a double take when i
saw it because it's just conflating two
issues that have no business being
intermingled right and i was thrilled uh
that we
did have such consensus around what
happened in uvalde i did not see anyone
in a pro-gun position or whatever
defending what the police officers did
it was just universal
that was an incredible dereliction of
duty what went on
but on the flip side what's going on
with the climate
is a very big deal it's very important
and and al gore has been on the
forefront of evangelizing the importance
of taking this seriously and making
small changes to big changes in your
life to ensure that we have a greener
planet or that we have a planet for
longer and
but hasn't done none of that i mean he
lives in a house that you know takes up
he lives i'm sure i don't know
and i don't people
in positions of power are often
hypocrites about these things and they
love to be in their private jets and
they love to go and open the canned film
festival with their you know climate
change is going to get us all movie or
whatever it is but the reaction to when
he says something like this which
is necessary in terms of pushing back on
the comparison to uvalde or any you know
holocaust denialism etc but
we need more people and positions of
power on the right on the republican
side to stand up and say climate change
is real man is contributing to this and
we need to take actional steps a
majority of americans want the federal
government to do more so jesse you know
the solutions from people like al gore
to get rid of things like fertilizer and
air conditioner which have enabled
humankind to survive like people will
die as a result of a lot of these these
proposals yeah he's just a climate shock
jock who says outrageous things for
money and attention
and i'm not going to give it to him he's
been wrong about everything the polar
bears the arctic ice cap pretty much
everything the sea levels rising 10 feet
that never happened i can see why though
people think the sea levels are rising i
have a theory it's more of a conspiracy
theory you know the cosmetics industry a
few years back how they said everyone
was gonna die from the sun unless you
buy their expensive creams and spf
lotions
that's not what's really happening so
everyone thinks they're gonna die from
the sun now so usually the pale people
in the family would bring an umbrella to
the beach and that only takes up a small
circumference now you see these tents at
the beach with these tent poles
they're so big you could host like a
wedding reception underneath them but
not everybody sits under the tent they
haul their bahama mama chairs out there
and they put them out like that and
surround the tent with them and they
need equipment for the hauling of the
bahama mamas or whatever they're called
tommy bahamas so they have like the one
dad in the family like bring like one of
those beach carts and that takes up
space and so no one can read anymore no
one can swim either so they had to bring
games now they bring cornhole and spike
and that like adds to the real estate
right yeah and then also they were so
worried about dehydration so they have
to bring so much water and juices and
gatorade they bring these yeti coolers
right you can fit a shark into these
things so it so you get to the beach and
like one family takes up like a hundred
yards of beach
and so it's not the beach is not
shrinking the sea levels aren't rising
it's just there's
big tents now
okay
all right people are still getting
perfect cancer yeah and sunburning their
eyeballs apparently today there was a
car driving on the beach oh man hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else